labyrinthine designs subtle symbology
and incredible effects run throughout
Hellraiser if you pay attention the
movie has such sights to show you
perhaps one of the most important and
memorable relics of the Hellraiser
franchise is the enigmatic puzzle box
that torments any Soul too curious to
let sleeping dogs lie the sonobites are
summoned into the realm of Mortals only
after an unsuspecting Soul completes a
puzzle known as the lament configuration
he have chosen the lament configuration
of course the rebooted film on Hulu
provides far more clarification on what
the lament configuration actually means
revealing that there are a variety of
solutions and Arrangements that yield
different results as well as a small
blade concealed in the Box to shed the
user's blood but during the film you
might notice several other allusions to
the cube beyond the puzzle box itself
the reboot doesn't shy away from
offering countless visual cues that
recall the lament configuration for
starters The Relic is kept in a square
safe in an empty container within the
safe the Box holding the demon summoning
artifact is also cubic in shape once
Riley and Trevor make their way to the
void to State the building while not
perfectly square revokes a puzzle box
with its nearly cubic design the ceiling
window of the manor is also a perfect
square and is how Voigt and Riley view
the emergence of the diamond-shaped god
Leviathan as it enters the physical
world the repeated visual Illusions to
mazes and labyrinths also recall the
design of the puzzle box itself
Hellraiser is a franchise Rife with
humans just as monstrous as the Demonic
figures and emerge to cause torment the
first film focuses on Frank Cotton a man
twisted up in his own selfish desires
after having an affair with his
brother's wife he is seemingly killed by
the cenobites after solving the puzzle
box later a small sampling of his
brother's blood brings him back to life
partially Frank uses his former flame
Julia to bring him sacrifices in the
form of dates she seduces to help him
rejuvenate fully as you would expect he
eventually betrays Julia in the second
film Julia is resurrected by Dr Philip
chanard she uses him just like Frank
used her and betrays Dr chanard the
trail it would seem as a common theme of
the franchise
in the sixth film Hellraiser hellseeker
Christy cotton returns to the franchise
now she is married to a man named Trevor
but she soon dies in a car accident
however the film's big reveal is that
Trevor plotted the death of his wife for
her inheritance but in a dark irony
Trevor is the one who actually perished
in the car accident Kirsty offers the
center by its Trevor in exchange for her
own life and the whole movie is about
Trevor living in his own version of Hell
whose Hellraiser features another man by
the name of Trevor this time played by
Drew Starkey who happens to be Riley's
newest boyfriend longtime fans of the
Hellraiser franchise almost certainly
picked up on Trevor's name and saw the
reveal of his deceit coming Boyd hired
him to lure Riley and her friends to his
Mansion so they could be sacrificed for
the Box
stylistically there aren't quite any
other creatures in cinema like the
cenobites of Hellraiser these tormented
Souls were once human but have been
transformed into monstrosities that
represent the epitome of human suffering
their bodily mutilations represent the
worst pain a body can endure and they
often have a connection to whoever the
person was in life the cenobites of the
classic films were often draped in black
leather the center bites of the latest
Hellraiser received a modern update gone
are the leather Duds of a bygone era
instead the cenobites designs are even
more heavily focused on the horrific
modifications made to their bodies the
hell priest for example retains the
sharp needles plunge into every square
inch of the Demon's head below their
neck chunks of Flesh are Stripped Away
and peeled back these sections have
absent skin along the cenobite's chest
resemble a tight leather strap design of
Doug Bradley's Pinhead if you look
closely you can see how the mutilations
carved into the Demon's flesh are homage
to the movie monstrous design old it's
just another way in which Hulu's
Hellraiser Endeavors to keep the spirit
of the franchise alive even in the
subtlest details
the cenobites don't play around whenever
the Box claims someone's blood they come
to collect but what happens to the poor
souls who die at the hands of these
interdimensional beings the classic
series often frame this other dimension
as hell and the victims that the
cenobites were trapped in a cycle of
Eternal torture and pain Hellbound
Hellraiser 2 depicted Frank's ghost
appearing to Kirsty to tell her he was
suffering in hell when he appears she
thinks he's the ghost of her late father
his body is entirely skinned only
showing bloody muscle and bone later
when Julia is resurrected she takes on
the same form a skinless monstrosity
that glistens in the light against her
bloody musculature it's one of the
grizzlier aspects of the original films
the new film briefly references the idea
of skinless Soul suffering in the
afterlife but instead of the beans
walking around without their skin the
moment is treated as a bit of a scare
for Riley while it's hard to miss this
detail it may have taken a moment for
those not well-versed in Hellraiser lore
to understand that it's more than a
simple scare Matt appears to Riley
inside the Voit Mansion when she
Embraces him she looks in the mirror
behind him and sees that she's hugging
Matt's bloody skin body the fates are
those claimed by the cinnabites are
damned indeed Hellraiser is big on
symbolism each of the Cube's
configurations represents different
aspects of the Eternal rewards the
cenobites had to offer while the puzzle
box was often referred to as the lament
configuration in the previous Hellraiser
films there are several more
configurations beyond that initial State
the next configuration is a hexagonal
shape when Riley breaks into the voida
stage she begins rifling through
anything she can find that will give her
more answers regarding the puzzle box
and the fate of her brother she
discovers mysterious drawings of each of
the cenobites she's about to encounter
more fun foreshadowing she also comes
across void's Journal which details his
research at the cube and its secrets on
the front of the book is the same
hexagonal shape that is seen when the
puzzle box is in its second
configuration inside the journal the six
configurations are explained the second
configuration is known as the lore
configuration this symbolizes knowledge
it's fitting that the book that contains
all avoids discoveries is marked with a
symbol of knowledge it's a fun detail
that's easily overlooked Hulu's
Hellraiser isn't a simple rehash of the
original movie or its sequels that's
ultimately what makes this latest film A
Thrill Ride for fans and newcomers alike
despite a different narrative the film
still draws parallels between its
characters and plot threads from the
first entries of the franchise one such
similarity is found in Roland Voigt
arguably the main villain of the new
film The cenobites can also be seen as
villains but they're mostly creatures of
habit who only punish The Morbid the
Curious it often takes a human motivated
by greed or the lust for power to enact
the horror that comes from the puzzle
box Voigt is a wealthy recluse who's
built his mansion in life around the
pursuit to the enduring life that the
lament configuration promises he's
become endlessly fascinated with the
lament configuration and has dedicated
all of his resources to unlocking its
Mysteries
foreign
while it may not be immediately clear
Voigt is truly a parallel to another
popular Hellraiser character Dr chanard
in the second film chernard is a
powerful man much like Voigt he's a
prestigious doctor obsessed with the
lament configuration janard acquires the
mattress where Julia was tormented and
killed by the cenobites in the first
film after offering a sacrifice she
emerges from the mattress and helps him
unlock the secrets of the moment
configuration which ultimately leads to
the labyrinth in the cenobite world she
betrays him and he becomes a cenobite
himself in the final moments of Hulu's
Hellraiser it's revealed that voids is
also transformed into a cenobite
Voight's Mansion has unique architecture
everything Roland void invested in had
something to do with the puzzle box and
his desire for the rewards that
potentially lie within he had no idea
how twisted the Santa bites and their
Leviathan God truly were nor did he
realize that no reward of theirs is
quite what it seems the Mansion
ultimately resembles the Labyrinth fans
witnessed in Hellbound Hellraiser II
Christy cotton as well as Dr chanard and
Julia plunge into the world of the
cenobites which appears to be one
massive maze with countless levels and
paths it's a strange scene but one that
ultimately becomes iconic in the
Hellraiser franchise as the
diamond-shaped God descends from the
skies above the labyrinth in Hulu's
Hellraiser reboot Boyd's Mansion has
many traps and rooms but more
interestingly the outside gate that
surrounds the entire structure is
constructed in a bizarre pattern the
gate is layered with lines squares and
rectangles they bring to mind the image
of the labyrinth seen from above in the
second Hellraiser film this imagery is
made even more apparent when we see the
diamond hovering over the Mansion at the
climax of the film there's no mistaking
that Boyd's Mansion is a reflex section
of the cenobite world and a brilliant
reference to Hellraiser lore the
cenobites are easily the stars of the
new film while we follow Riley in her
quest to put a stop to the Horus of the
puzzle box it's the Twisted
interdimensional demons that we're here
for aside from the hell priest's iconic
head and the chatterers gnashing maw the
cenobites in the new film have gotten a
massive redesign therefore we have
plenty of new monstrosities to gawk at
what's even more horrifying about the
cenobites is that their mutilations
depict flesh that is still alive and
moving underneath their creepy exterior
a lot of special effects work and
Prosthetics went into these designs to
ensure they were depicted as gruesomely
real as possible for instance there is
one cenobite known as the gasp she's the
cenobite with a facial piercings and a
bowing metal rod across her forehead
that stretches out her skin even more
disturbing is that the skin over her
throat is peeled away and spread wide
open when she talks attendant viewers
can see her vocal cords and the muscles
around them vibrate it simultaneously
horrific and awesome the attention to
detail in each of these cenobite designs
is top notch the rebooted film is truly
a reimagining of the work Clive Barker
began all those years ago it honors the
legacy of his creation but manages to
inject more lore into the franchise but
The Inspirations for many of the newest
films elements are pretty clear if
you're familiar with the film series
Riley takes center stage in this reboots
as an unfortunate soul who accidentally
mingles with the powers of Darkness
forces Beyond her control toss her
friends into the meat grinder her
brother is the first casualty and the
one she hopes to save with the power of
Resurrection she sees his ghostly Visage
and realizes he's living in eternal
torment ultimately she knows that
there's nothing the cenobites can offer
that truly Grande her what she wants
Christy cotton from the original films
goes through a similar experience she
evades the cenobites but her father is
killed in the process she believes that
she sees his Spirit telling her that
he's suffering in hell and her goal is
to find him and save him while the story
operates a bit differently there are
definite parallels between Riley and
kirsty's journey visually it's also hard
to deny that the brown curly hair is
shared by both films heroines evokes a
sense of similarity Riley and Kirsty
bull survived the ordeo but they have to
live with the loss they've endured
thanks to the scheming people in their
lives who sought to wield other worldly
power at a tragic cost what's your
pleasure sir
[Music]